(intense music)
- I'm a sighted person.
- I am a sighted person.
(intense music continues)
- Everybody described the
color red right now go.
- I feel like you can't
really describe.
- Yes you can. Go, go, go.
You're wasting time.
- It's... (laughing)
I don't know.
The target logo like?
- Okay.
- Oh, very red.
Very, very red.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay, cool, cool
cool.
- Right.
- There you go Iggy.
- Red, that (beep) is beautiful.
It's like bright and like it's so...
It's blood girl. It's blood.
- That's a good one.
- I was looking to see
if people were gonna get
like overly descriptive about things
because that to me just logically felt
like it would've been like a tell.
- It's a vibrant color to me.
I'm actually wearing a
red top right now so.
(laughing) I think it's vibrant.
It's, I associate it to strawberries.
I don't know apples. (laughs)
- So for me, I associate
red with fire chili peppers.
It's one of my favorite colors to wear.
I'm wearing red lipstick.
- I have a question, does anybody
like fabric the way that it feels?
- I hate soft stuff.
- You hate soft
stuff?
- I cannot stand soft stuff.
Like that really soft blanket, not for me.
- I love like the feeling
of like real leather,
like I'm sorry to the cows.
(cow mooing)
(all laughing)
- Can everybody say what they do?
- I am a author and I write
comic books and novels.
I also do photography and I paint.
- Cool.
- Oh nice. Yeah for me, I'm
actually a a school counselor
and a vocalist as well.
- I work for a non-profit that helps kids
with medical conditions.
- You're such a good person.
(all laughing)
- I was anxious that
people were gonna think
that I was the mole,
I think that anything like
that's more like on the philanthropy side,
people would kind of
assume would have a reason.
Like if you have some
kind of medical condition
then you would wanna help other people
with that same medical condition.
- I have a question for you guys as well.
What is the first thing
that you guys notice
when you walk in a room?
- Oh.
- Color of the walls I
would say, or wallpaper.
I'm really, like I said, home
decor's a really big deal.
- There's other people.
- Yeah.
(clock ringing)
(upbeat music)
- Oh, already?
- [Cameraman] Don't come
back Taylor, please.
- It's really hard to
describe the color red.
- Who was the hottest U.S. president?
(contestants chatting)
- Are we looking at paintings here?
Are we going back and looking
at the old paintings though?
- Oh, I love... (laughs)
- Because, and by the way
the wigs did take away.
- It's the toss up between
Barack Obama and JFK for me.
- Oh, you know? You know what?
Yeah.
- Barack Obama's handsome man.
- I'd say Teddy Roosevelt
just 'cause I know like
"Night of the Museum,"
like that's all I'm
going off of pretty much.
- I'm sorry.
(contestants laughing)
- [Micheal] That's it.
- Teach their own my
friend. Teach their own.
- Okay, so what is
everybody's favorite movie?
- I'd say "Pursuit of
Happiness". I love that film.
It's a great.
- Oh, I cried.
- Yeah, same.
(Micheal laughing)
- "Everything, Everywhere, All at Once".
- Oh my god, I was gonna say that.
- I haven't seen it yet either.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry okay, I'm sorry.
- But the costume design, I'm
just gonna say that was...
- Can anyone describe like a scene
from a movie that they really enjoyed?
- Oh, that's a good.
(contestants chatting)
- That's a good one.
- Can we do TV shows 'cause I..
- Sure.
- 'Cause I'm a TV person.
- Yeah, sure.
- I'm watching right now,
"A House of Dragons."
(Iggy grunting)
- Do you remember that
gold dress that she has
with the sleeves that hang down?
- Yes.
- And then she had the delicate
like those beautiful gold earrings.
I like the outfits of "Game of Thrones,"
but also the fact that it was like that
it's not quite super red,
but burnt red dragon.
- I felt like
that was just kind of oak for compensating
for something and it
seemed a little suspicious.
- Does anybody have any pets?
- Lots of cats.
- Yeah, I have two dogs.
- I have a dog, a cat, and
a tortoise and some fish.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
- What's your tortoise's name?
- Squishy.
- Squishy?
- (contestants laughing) The logical,
the logical name and it's so cute.
I love the way he looks at me
and my cat's hairless so she runs around.
- [Contestants] Aww.
- Yeah. And she stares
into the fire in winter.
- [Cameraman] That is time.
(clock ringing)
(intense music)
- I'm an author so I describe
things all day in my books
and that definitely got voted off for that
and I probably would've voted for me too.
- [Cameraman] If you wanna keep playing
because you think the mole is still there,
raise your hand in count three, okay?
One, two, three.
(contestants laughing)
All right guys this is
the same deal except
remember how I said there
was gonna be a secret rule
implemented half way through?
Every incorrect person voted out
will take away the cash prize.
And your five minutes starts now.
- Okay. Describe your
perfect type physically?
- I don't think I have like
a specific type physically.
Like, I think I just like vibes, you know?
I feel like that's not
the correct answer here.
(laughing) But I mean, I don't know,
I just, I like who I like
I don't really like pay attention to,
to like, yeah. I don't know.
- I think it's you now by the way.
Definitely tall, I'm not
super into incredibly like fit dudes
'cause that makes me feel inadequate.
I love like a little,
I love a little chunky
like a Seth Logan build, but like tall,
basically.
- Dad buds?
- Yeah. Tall guys with dad buds.
- I personally look at their smile first,
I think that's really important to me.
And you know, that kind of gives me
an indication if we're vibing or not.
And if it's like a fake
smile or, you know,
so I think I notice that first.
- I say, I mean I feel
like this is pretty basic,
but like, nice eyes, like nice eyes.
I've also been with the same person
for like two and a half years, so.
- Aww.
- Shout out to her.
- Tall brown hair, nice eyes.
I really like gravitate
towards brown eyes.
I think they're really like sweet,
you know they're really welcoming.
- I have a question then.
How is everyone's vision?
Like, do you wear glasses, contacts?
- Okay. I'm gonna be really honest here.
And this might, I am legally
blind in my right eye.
- That's either the world's best bluff
and a great strategy or like,
you're just being honest.
- I wear glasses.
- Okay. Get her out. Get her out
- Technical then what does that mean?
- So my right eye, I could see out of it.
Like it's fine, my glasses
are thick on the right side.
- Does it feel lopsided,
like on your head carrying?
- Yeah. So, when I first put them on,
when I walk it's like, whoa
like it just looks like crazy.
So I will never have 2020 Vision in
my right eye will never be perfect
even with glasses on.
- What's the last concert
you guys have been to?
- I went to a freaking, I
went to a "Halsey concert"
because a friend had a shut up,
a friend had an extra ticket
and they were just like, "do
you wanna go see Halsey?"
And I was like, fine.
- I went at "The Weekend concert,"
The one that he canceled?
(Iggy grunting)
- Yeah, the one that he canceled.
Oh, it was, was, Yeah. It really sucked.
(laughing) But it's okay. We understand.
We're pathetic towards him. You know?
- I haven't been to a
concert in a while but,
I'm going to "The Harry
Styles Concert," in November
it will be great.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- That's so lit.
- It's gonna be awesome.
- Ashley, I had a question for you.
- The children that you help,
what disability do they have?
- It's not a disability,
it's just life threatening
medical conditions.
- Just?
- I mean it, I mean some
of them are disabled
but like not all of them
are, you know what I mean?
So to qualify-- (clock ringing)
(intense music)
- I'm sorry.
- I knew this was gonna
happen, I was just being honest
and I feel like I knew
that was gonna happen.
- Everybody was just
trying to look for somebody
and so I was the obvious choice.
- Rebecca sweetie. I'm so sorry.
- [Cameraman] Do you think the
mole is still in this circle?
Raise your hand on three.
One, two, three.
And the majority has voted
that they think the mole is out
and we are going to stop playing.
And the four of you standing up there
may take your blindfolds off.
(intense music)
- Oh hell yeah. Hell yeah. Hell yeah.
- Okay guys on three,
you can all take off your blindfolds okay?
One, two, three.
(intense music)
- I knew it. I knew it.
- I did not.
- I'm actually happy 'cause
like the second you guys
started talking about
eyesight and glasses,
I'm like, Oh God, that's
too much too make up.
- That's what I get for being honest.
- I knew that.
- I only went blind, started
going blind five years ago.
Started going deaf last year.
- Okay, so you still knew how
to describe everything that
we were talking about like earlier?
- So everything that I said is true.
Yeah, because you just,
because you do the spectrum of blindness,
you could be totally in the dark
or you can go dark later on.
I lost the majority of my
vision overnight at 22 years old
which was a gigantic shock.
But I learned a lot
about myself and my life
and I wouldn't go back and change it.
I wouldn't have the
life that I have today,
I wouldn't appreciate
what I have today and
I love me and I just happen to be blind.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my God. Is this real money?
This is so much.
This is a lot.
- Don't throw it.
- Oh my God, I feel like a stripper.
I love it. I love it.
Yes, it's real.